okay so I guess uh let's get started so
um
so today this lecture we are going to
discuss
um a few small stuff
um that that are remains uh that are
kind of like a left from previous
lectures and then we are going to move
on to as far as learning so
um so I guess the first thing is that
um recall that last time
we talk about uh in place regularization
of the noise
and
and we mentioned that
um in certain cases you can prove that
the regularizer prefers the the noise
noisy STD
noisy GD prefers
um smaller
on this quantity R Theta which is
defined to be something like the trace
of the housing
so and
and in the first part of this lecture
I'm explaining you I'm going to spend
probably 10 to 15 minutes to briefly
discuss why this is a reasonable thing
to uh try to minimize or try to kind of
like
regularize so why the choice of the
housing is some meaningful quantity or
you know but this part wouldn't be
exactly kind of like rigorous because
you have to do some approximations so
and so forth but I'm just going to do
some kind of like a somewhat heuristic
Eurovision to justify why something like
the Hassan would be useful for us to
recognize
so I I guess so the thing is that how do
we uh what is the heising right what is
the Hyacinth and maybe actually I'll
actually write I will hide this is the
empirical the housing on the empirical
loss so maybe uh for Simplicity let's
only consider
um let's only consider
one data point
so and let's say suppose f
as the node I have to be f
comma Theta this is the I guess maybe I
should say
I have to say like X
um without model output
and let
um
l f y be the loss function
um then what you can do is that you can
compute so then L Theta in this case is
just the L of
you know F Theta X Y right
so in this case then we can compute what
the hessing is so the hessing
maybe let's call this L hat just
to be consistent in terms of notation
The Hyphen is the gradient of the
gradient now what's the gradient if you
use chain rule what you're going to get
is that you get L the partial L over
partial f
times partial F over partial Theta
so this is nabla
um
the derivative is back to so so this is
a scalar function L is a is a function
of F but this is a very simple function
right because L is a scalar f is a
scalar so so this is a scalar and times
the gradient of f Theta attacks
so and now you are taking a gradient of
a paradox of two quantities by the
scalar and the other is a gradient and
then you can do chain rule what you're
going to get is that you first for
example do the gradient respect to the
first part what you got is
um
uh let me see what you got from the
first one is that you have l
the second hour derivative with respect
to F and then you do the chain rule you
get
this upside down X so this is going in
with respect to Theta times greater than
F Theta X transpose and this is the
in some sense that the so this part is
the gradient of this and this part is
copying
I guess
uh this is copying from here in some
sense
um but I guess you know this is
something that you can verify offline
like if you do all the kind of like uh
if you look at all the coordinates and
and do all the calculation and then you
can also do the uh the the chain rule
for the other part so what you can get
is the the
the L over DF times the second order
derivative of the model
Theta at X
The Matrix
of Dimension P by P if p is the number
of parameter
and and this is a scalar this is the
scalar and this is a vector this is a
vector
so the whole thing is the P by P Matrix
so when you have a suppose your loss so
this is a general formula which is just
a rigorously true and suppose the loss
function
uh is uh ilf
Y is equals to for example a half times
y minus F squared
then this formula becomes
what is the second order derivative of
this loss function with respect to f
its function is a quadratic function of
fact the loss function is a quadratic
function with respect to F and the
leading term is f squared so the loss
the height the second order of the
respect to F is one so this is equals to
1 times squareian state
of f times the green of f Theta
transpose
and then the first R derivative will be
um respect to F will be F minus y
times the housing
after the X
so so this decomposition is often called
uh so so what you can see is that this
is a convex term
this is this is a PSD term sorry
this is PSD because it is uh the outer
product of a random Matrix and this is
non-active and and this is not necessary
PSD
so the heising may not be PSD in general
of course right because you have a
non-convex function but one of the term
is PSD
and if you have it in general if you
have a convex else function the first
term so in China this is called
this is called um I don't know why this
is called this but it's called ghost
Newton decomposition
um I think we must have something to do
with these two famous people at some
point but it's called ghost
decomposition and in general the first
term
this is always so is always positive for
con for
convex loss function
but I guess by loss function I really
mean that the literally the top the the
chord either quadratic loss of or kind
of like um
um or cross entropy lost they're all
convex right so this term in almost all
cases where you we study the the first
term
um this is non-zero so the first term is
this is PSD
PSE
and in parallel people found that the
second term in most of cases is small
so there could be multiple reasons for
this so empirically
the second term
F minus y
does
is generally smaller
and one of the reason it could be that
you know at least when you are at a
global minimum this term is zero so when
Theta
is I tell a gullible mean
so meaning
if Theta X is equals to Y right so glow
mean would fit the data exactly so in
this case then this term is actually
literally zero so F minus y
zero
so this could be one reason why
empirical the second term is relatively
small and of course this is not always
true it's not always you can fill the
data at any point but somehow people
found that on the second term you know
is somewhat smaller than the first term
so if you don't care about anything
super
if you don't care about a very
nuanced kind of qualities but it hasn't
in the first term is a reasonable
approximation for that of course you
know in certain cases you do care about
nuances for example when you care about
whether this function is convex or not
you should talk about even any
non-negative eigenvalue would make it
non-conflex right so then the second
term becomes important but if you just
have a choice then the second term is
not that important
so that's the
um that's the rough intuition and now
suppose we know the second term this is
a a big assumption but suppose ignoring
the second term
then we can see what's the trace of the
housing
second term
so the trace of the housing you know for
whatever reason right for example you
can ignore it just because it's in
perfectly small you can ignore it
because you are at a global minimum but
suppose you ignore the second term then
the the trace of the hashing
and Theta is approximately equals to
this
derivative is equal to Y which is
probably one if you have square loss
times the
the um
the trace of this
transpose
which is equals to
some scalar times the true Norm of the
gradient
so you can see that by minimizing the
trace of the testing you are minimizing
the L2 Norm
of the of the loop systems with back to
the parameter
so this is so minimizing
the Trees of the housing
is somewhat similar heuristically
minimizing
the business
of the model
with respect to Theta
um
and I think so why minimizing Ellipsis
of the model with respect to Theta is
useful actually first of all this is
indeed useful if you just expressly
minimize this and people have found that
empirical this is useful and and why
this is useful you know if you allow
some heuristics you know you can also
say that this is very similar to uh the
minimizing the lipsyness
of the model output
with respect to
the hidden variables
I think this is something that we
discussed probably like
a few weeks ago when we talk about the
Euler margins so recall that if you have
a generator which consists of for
example a bunch of layers
suppose you have a deep networks with a
lot of weights and then the derivative
of the model with reflects to some
layer I this is equals to the derivative
of the model with respect to the layer
um above it times the layer uh
let me see so this is H A plus one times
h i minus 1 transpose
so this is the the so-called okay I
guess now I remember the it's called
hiding rule
you know but it's actually just a
lateral layer
a simple chain rule
in the in the in a neuroscience this is
called having rule
um but but actually it's just a real
change we want to take the derivative
with respect the parameter and the
parameter kind of come into play that
depends on each and as one and h i plus
one and sorry this is H1
so what is h so so here h i plus 1
is
uh
W Times h i
right so this is the ith layer
and this is the pre-activation
of a possible layer
I guess maybe technical I should call
this h i Prime just so that I can
distinguish it from poster calibration
but I guess you get the point the point
is that
if you take the derivative with the
structure parameter it's actually very
closely related to the derivative with
respect to a hidden variable and a norm
of the Hidden variable H5 right so this
means that
that you create a norm
if you leave the Matrix and it's a
forbidden storm of this is equals to
Norm times the H1
so minimizing the
the deluxiousness with respect to the
parameters is similarly is similar to
minimizing the deliciousness with
respect to Hidden variable
I think this is something we have
discussed before
um when we do the Euler margin right so
then when you talk about the derivative
of the Hidden variable then this is kind
of like all their margin
I guess you're Max making earlier March
because Euler margin is bigger if you
have you know more Ellipsis model you
have a lot larger Euler margin so
none of these steps can be made 100
rigorous you know some of the
intermediate equations that I've written
are exactly true but I don't think all
of these steps can be made completely
rigorous but you know sometimes this is
probably the nature of new networks
right you cannot be 100 precise just
because things don't match exactly but I
think the intuition
um is really just that the hashing
the the hessing relates to the lipsense
of the model with Vector parameter and
the largest of the model with Vector
parameter relates to the lip system of
the model with hidden variables which is
kind of like captured well very much
um
any questions
foreign
this is the first thing about
um
this is the remaining steps
um the remaining remarks from the last
lecture about the implicit
regularization of the noise and
there's another thing I want to discuss
which is something I in some sense it's
my Omission I forgot how to provide the
proof for one of the theorems that we
discussed I think two weeks ago about
the implicit requisition effect in the
classification case
um I think there we only basically at
the end of that lecture we only were
able to kind of provide the theorem
under the basic intuition
um so but we weren't able to really show
the proof the proof is very simple and
short like just the one page I think
it's very nice proof so I really want to
show it to you so so maybe let's discuss
that uh in the next part
so I will remind you what is the what
the theorem was was about so guys so
just um
this is a
two I think two lectures ago
so two lectures ago we showed the
following theorem the theorem was
something like
suppose you have maybe the context
is that we have linear model
classification
um and we have a gradient flow
we have infinite small
um infinitesimal learning rate and one
understands what's the implicit bias of
the algorithm in this case
and the theorem that we had was that
gradient flow
um convert this to
the direction
[Music]
of
the max margin solution
um in the sense that
so the margin of your interest rate
is converging to the max margin solution
as T goes to Infinity
so here WT is iterate
um of green descent
at time t
of good in flow at time t
so and Gamma is the normalized margin
and Gamma bar is the next margin
Max normalized Mars
I think at the end of the lecture I
think I I discussed the intuition the
main intuition is that the cross entropy
laws is really
basically you can do an approximation
and in certain cases the cross entropy
laws is a approximation
um
of the max margin so the main intuition
if you recall that lecture I I was just
very very briefly on summarize this so
the main question is that if you do a
bunch of kind of heuristical calculation
you can find out that the log of the
laws is approximately
equals to
um
let's see
so log of laws is approximately equals
to
um
minus
times the norm of w
[Music]
times the gamma W so basically
minimizing a loss is kind of like either
you want to make the norm of w bigger or
you want to make the margin bigger
so we did this very heuristic heuristic
uh simplification
give you this
so that's why if you want to minimize
the loss in some sense you are either
trying trying to make the norm bigger or
you're trying to make the margin bigger
and it turns out that you can actually
control uh both of these two you know
forces these two kind of like tendency
and if it's actually true that the norm
is growing and the margin is also
growing both of them are trying to be
big and and you can show that the norm
grows you know to its frequency and the
margin grows to the moderate there are
smarter so that's the thing we're going
to prove in this theorem
um any questions so far
and and one of the key thing that we
discussed at that point was that the the
log some exponential on one of the key
technique is that logs some exponential
just kind of like the same as Max
um if if your input is uh has a has a
has a large scale
so so today I'm going to provide a
formal proof for this
theorem which is actually pretty in my
opinion it's very elegant and simple
and we only prove it for
proof for only the case when the loss
function
is
minus exponential T like the exponential
loss recall that in that lecture we also
discussed that
the logistic laws even though it's
called logistic loss it's actually very
close to exponential loss
um
um so so so so we only deal with logic
exponential loss which is kind of almost
the same as the logisticals so the main
feature is that as T goes to Infinity
the loss goes to zero so the t is the
supposed to be the margin and then when
the margin is very very big and your
loss is very small
so and the
the idea is that we can consider the
smooth margin
so the smooth margin is defined to be
I think in the last in the lecture we
Define a smooth margin to be
let me find out the
time
okay so I'm looking right
okay so the smooth margin is defined to
be the following so consider the smooth
margin
so the smooth margin is defined to be
the log
of the empirical loss
over the true Norm of w
so recall that we have try to accept
minus log so we have established this
equation
last time during the intuition and that
actually motivates the use of the smooth
margin you can see that the smooth
margin
it's basically supposed to be
approximately equals to the margin gamma
of w right if this approximation is true
but it's not exactly equal to that just
because this this is only approximately
equals to so that's why we we work with
this smoother version which is um
in some sense like
almost the same as the margin but just
the more kind of closer to the loss
function I will have
and if you work with the smooth margin
you can show that the smooth margin is
actually uh I guess we have proved this
in the last lecture so the the margin is
actually bigger than a smooth margin
um
so guys uh
maybe let's just write out exactly what
is this is minus log
some well exponential minus
y i times W transpose x i
don't know of w
and and you can show that the margin
is larger than a smooth margin
that's because you can replace each of
these terms by the maximum by the
minimum right this is just because
y i w transpose x i is less than
gamma W Times the norm of w
sorry this is larger than this
so the simplest margin is supposed to be
something close to the margin but
smaller so that's why it's the fastest
to show
that the smooth margin L gamma tilde W
converges to
on gamma bar
wh homologist
this is because you know you have this
sandwich thing right so you know that
gamma W is always then gamma bar so so
basically the smooth margin is
sandwiched between
um so so if the smooth margin Commerce
to the gamma bar then gamma W has to
converge the gamma bar because there's
no way for gamma W to go beyond gamma
bar
okay so so now basically this is what
we're going to do we're going to prove
that even a smaller value the smooth
margin is going to converge to gamma bar
um so then the larger value will also
converge to gamma bar
so and and the proof is actually also
pretty simple so we basically show that
uh we'll show
the gradient flow will increase
um the
this quantity the log of the WT
log of the log the log loss
uh by because it
decreases
you know intuitively because it
decreases L hat WT
so let's do this formally
so concretely
because I think you know the statement
itself right it will increase system
minus of the log loss that's kind of
like almost obvious because the the loss
itself is going to decrease but how much
it increases requires some kind of
mathematical derivation
so concretely suppose recall that
the change in W is minus gradient LWT
this is the definition of the gradient
flow then what you have is that
the derivative with respect to T
um
of the chain
the changes in the log the minus of the
log loss
is equals to
so how does this change this you take
the chain rule right so you first look
at how does the loss depends on
w
and then you look at how does w change
and how does the loss depends on W so
does the derivative so then this is like
a derivative of this which is minus
uh minus
you use the chain rule again so we get L
of WT
is the chain rule for the log and above
you get the gradient of L hat
w
and then
um w dot
and we call it w dot T is really the
gradient of the loss function so
basically our up to our sign so
basically you get
the gradient of the loss function
to Norm Square over L of w t
and this is vigram 0. so this shows that
it's minus log loss is going to increase
as T goes to Infinity
and and but the important thing is how
how fast it increases is this quantity
this is something we're going to use
this is this whole thing is increasing
it's not surprising because the loss is
decreasing but this we also want to know
how fast this is increasing and by the
way you can actually I think it's useful
to
use the this because we're going to
compare it with
you can also write this as this equals
to this just because the number of L hat
is just equals to w dot t
Okay so now
with this we can what we can do is that
we can control
uh what eventually after t-step what
happens with the the log blocks so what
you get is that minus log
L hat w t
uh is equals to minus log l hat w0
plus the integral between 0 and T of the
derivative of this quantity
so and this is going to be using the
equation above you've got that this log
compute 0 Plus
the integral of w Del t
for Norm Square over L Double H
okay so so we basically know now know
how fast you know how large is the is
the log loss right so recall that what
we care about is this quantity
what we care about is
[Music]
what we care about is this
and how does this goes to it how does
this go to gamma bar as T goes to
Infinity
um so and we have already deal with the
the denot the numerator and we just have
to kind of like we know how does this
someone know how does this change uh for
the numerator and we have to again
another thing is that we have to kind of
like um
uh try to understand
um the denominator right so the
denominator you know you have to
normalize this by the norm of w
so
um so basically next thing is that we're
going to deal with this term and compare
it with the normalizer norm of w so what
you do is that you look at the w dot T
Square
this is bigger than
w dot T times
W star
recall
W star
is the direction
[Music]
of Max margin solution
this is just by caution shorts right so
the inner part of two vectors is less
than the norm of one vector times the
norm of the other vector and the norm of
the double star is assumed to be one
so then we plug in
the definition
of w dot
is minus green l w t
h w star
and then we plug in the true definition
of the number l so
like we plug in a derivation for the
number l so this
equals to y i times exponential minus y
i x
W transpose x i
times x i
and times W star
and then this is a vector this is a
scalar this is a scalar so basically you
can just take inner part of these two
and multiply the scalar
so this will be equals to
[Music]
um I guess there's no minus here because
the there's another minus in the
gradient which cancels so then this is
equals to sum
of y i times exponential minus y i
double transpose x i
times double star times x i
guess maybe let's write this
W star transpose x i
so
and this we can see that this is the
margin of the the max margin because W
star is the max margin solution so this
is always bigger than the max margin so
so so this is larger than
comma bar times
I guess
let me write let me finish it let me
explain
because
why I
double star principles x i
is bigger than gamma bar this is just
because gamma bar is the margin of w
star so that's why every data point has
a bigger margin than the
so and then this is equals to gamma Bar
times the loss
so with this then we can proceed by
dealing with we can proceed by dealing
with this term to further lower bounds
how
kind of control how fast you you grow so
with this you get log l hat WT
is lower than minus log l hat w
zero
uh
follow us
um
so maybe maybe just one moment before I
use this let me just try to interpret
what this is really doing so this
see so
[Music]
so so in some sense as a remark what is
this this is really doing is that so WT
we show the WT so we show that
WT is correlated
with W star
all right that's what we are showing
right so we are showing that the
the w dot T times W star is bigger than
a normal active quantity and the whole
card is this depends on the correlation
depends on
gamma bar and loss
so so in some sense the and and because
you according with W star it means that
you you cannot double dot T itself
cannot be too small
so and also so this is another thing we
got right so w dot t
is not too small
at least compared to
the laws
so so so so what this is saying is that
you know if the loss is not too small
then you have to make some changes in
your in your w and if you have to make
some changes in your W then you have to
make some changes in the log of the L
hat WT so basically if the loss is not
small then you log of the loss needs to
increase the minus log of the loss needs
to increase
so it's a little kind of like a
counterintuitive in some sense but I
guess so so what we do next is that
let's control this term additional term
that that's circled here so this term
if we use the
the equation we got we we got this is
larger than gamma bar
times
depends out one of the law the law or
you you can you can use this for one of
the there is a power two here right you
can use the equation maybe let's get
this equation one for one of this
occurrences of w dot t
so then you got you you're left with one
and then you got
the command bar and I had our head got
canceled with the denominator and a
comma bar is put in the front so we got
this
so basically I'm applying equation one
for one of the w.t2 not
and then you can use a triangle
inequality
this is by one
it was a triangularity to say that this
is larger than
the integral of w dot T three Norm
Square DT
foreign
this is replacing the integral with the
norm then you get gamma Bar times
the norm of WT
so guys you know next you're going to
see why we kept all of this because we
care about this because
now you can
control how fast
L height
is log loss it's improving
compared to
how fast the norm of w is improving
foreign
about because fundamentally we care
about the ratio between them it's the
definition of the soft margin or the
smooth margin
so this means that a ratio
is
getting closer to gamma bar right so
this term is a constant and this term
is something that becomes closer to zero
as T goes to Infinity
so so WT
goes to Infinity as T goes to zero uh as
d goes to Infinity okay
that's why this term
here
converts to zero as T goes to Infinity
so that's why
if you're taking the limit
when T goes to Infinity
regard that this
smooth margin right so we call that this
ratio is the smooth margin it's
converging to gamma bar
so in other words the limit T's Infinity
the Matilda
W T is equals to Common power
maybe here you only can an active and
then you use the other way to show that
and you also know that okay so we also
know
gamma bar is larger than a margin of any
w
because gamma bar is the max margin and
which is larger than
WT
and then you can show that the learn
much is actually equally equal to gamma
bar exactly
so we're done
any questions
okay so I guess with this we basically
concluded our section
um about our implicit regularization so
I guess just to very quickly briefly
wrap up so this is the end of the
the section about implicit
regularization
and we have talked about a bunch of
things like initialization
so small initialization prefers certain
kind of solution typically you know
um small Norm solution
prefers you know small Norm solution
and and we are actually in one of the
cases we also show that you know you can
have an interpolation between small and
transition large initialization so in
that case you can show the implicit bias
for any initialization
and we also talk about the the
classification problem
so where you get the max margin
so this is where you get Max margin
solution
and we also talk about a lot of the
stock the noise
so in all these cases it's kind of like
you have something about you know your
optimizer
that is only designed for optimizing
faster in some sense right but somehow
as a side effect you get implicit
regularization effect
foreign
okay so if there's no questions let me
move on to
um
the final part of this lecture of this
course which is about more about
answering reputation and so and so forth
so
so then so in this lecture and the last
two two launches we still have like so
basically next 2.5 lectures we're going
to talk about answering
they are not that many
uh theoretical work about answering of
course there are a lot of like um
very amazing empirical works these days
um like uh but not many or theoretical
work so what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to start with
somewhat kind of classical approach a
little bit so for this lecture and the
the beginning of the second next lecture
maybe a good portion of the next lecture
I'm going to talk about the classical
approach
uh I mean crackle theoretical approach
so there are many many approaches you
know before for example the most
empirically probably
um before deep learning the best
empirical approach would be probably
like you do later variable models with
um em expectation maximization but I'm
going to for those kind of eon
algorithms there are very little
theoretical analysis and even there is
analysis is kind of like a special case
and it's not clear whether they can be
extended to
um
or a complex case so what I'm going to
talk about is a different line of
research which used the so-called moment
method
so so this kind of methods you know
don't necessarily work very well for
uh uh empirically but they have very
good um uh you can analyze them in a
very clean way and then this kind of
mathematical techniques are also useful
for many other cases so I think it's
worth spending one lecture to talk about
this uh this approach and it used to be
the case that actually around probably
2012 2013 at that point I think the
community the theoretic Community
thought that this might be the new thing
it could be the new thing that you can
both analyze and empirically uh work
um it turns out that the analysis part
you know developed got developed very
well but the empirical part you know
it's doing okay but not kind of like
good enough to replace the EM algorithms
at least not enough to replace them
completely
so
um so so and then I'm going to talk
about some of the more modern
work
uh with with deep learning
with deep learning like for example
self-tuning
or contrastive learning
so these are basically analysis in the
last
wow two years about some of the new
algorithms in deep learning
um
um so I'm going to spend probably the
last lecture and the last 1.5 lectures
on this
okay so that's the plan for the next 2.5
lecture and
so today I'm going to talk about a
classical approach right so
um
and by the way another kind of General
comment is that in my opinion this
answering seems to be the core for many
things right so this also relates to
for example semi surprise learning where
you have some unlabeled data together
with label data
and this also relates to unsurprised
domain adaptation
and my personal opinion is that all of
these questions like what really you
care about is really
like in both of these questions what you
really care about is how do you leverage
unlabeled data so in some sense they all
reduces to under an expression in my in
my opinion
um
okay so now let's get into uh something
more concrete
so
um
so let's say let's have some setup so
um this is the setup
this is worse you know
18 variable models latent variable
models
so we are interested in those
conflicting variable models especially
in a classical approach so the the
formulation is that you have a
distribution
P Theta
parametrical space data
how is parameters Theta that would be
you know
there are many different ways which I'm
going to introduce a few of them but
every parameter decides a distribution P
Theta and then you are given
uh unlabeled examples right there's no
labels anywhere right so you're given
examples you know X1 after X and they
are sample ID from these distributions P
Theta and your goal
is to recover
data
online data from the data
from data
so that's the that's the formulation
and P Theta can be described you know as
a latent variable model
or can't be or typically is described
by
um a latent variable model
so every state that describes your
genetic model in some sense so for
example
um I assume you somehow know roughly
speaking what latent variable model is
from cs29 but let me give some examples
for example mix of gaussian
this is one of the probably
um the most studied
distribution in machine learning so so
the assumption is that in the most
General sense
the Theta
is so the parameters are
um describe a bunch of things
so let me write it down first so you
have a bunch of vectors
hey vectors and a probability
a bunch of probability numbers so each
of these mu I is
in dimension D is the mean
of the component
and and P1 up to PK this is a
probability vector
um in in the Simplex right let's call it
data k
a simple action K Dimension which is
basically
a set of vectors with Norm one Norm
sorry Norm equals to one
and non-negative
and in dimension k
right so people have to PK is a
probability Vector over K items
right so and given these parameters
what's the model how do you generate so
this is my parameter and how do you
generate data so it's mixed of thousands
so so intuitively you just you want to
model the case where you have for
example
something like this you have a
you have several clusters of data
something like this
I guess you don't see the color
um in in the data you just see the raw
inputs the color is just to indicate
which gaussians come from so so
mathematically you say that you sample X
from P Theta
uh by
your first assemble some I the cluster
ID from a categorical
distribution defined by P
so so I is you know between I I can take
values from 1 to K and then given the ID
the cluster ID you sample a gaussian
which means mu sub I
and then some covers let's say identity
so actually the covariance can also be a
parameter you want to learn but here for
Simplicity I just assume all the
quotients have the same code bar it's
just to make this
like the uh everything easier
so so this is the latent variable model
so where I is the latent variable
this is something you don't observe
in your data you only observe X but uh
but given the latent variable you can
generate the data so you so basically
there are two separate two parts where
you first generating variable and then
you generate data
um I don't know under the under the hood
and then many other approach which uh
I'm going to Define probably mostly when
I'm using I I'm going to use it so hmm
the hidden variable mode hidden Markov
model
because if you take some NLP class
probably have seen this kind of things
or ICA independent component analysis
this is um
also something I think
covered in
um cs209
and so there are many many other kind of
like relating variable more space not so
and so forth so
so this is the final of questions we're
going to study
and now let's talk about the approach so
the approach
maybe before that any questions
okay so the approach uh
we're gonna study is the so-called
moment method which is actually pretty
powerful
uh either as a approach there are some
drawbacks you know which make it
empirical urbanized appealing but the
approach itself if you don't
have a certain kind of like aspects then
it's actually pretty powerful this is
called moment method
I think this method is proposed by
actually
um Economist uh or actually a few
economic economists uh to understand
data from economy
um like from economists
um
um from like uh I think Michael
I don't know I don't know like some kind
of like a you know so the the original
source is definitely not machine
learning but then people use this for
machine learning these days which is
actually pretty complicated
um approach
um actually even though I think
actually I I think I I missed me spoke
the the very original proposal of this
movement method actually probably dates
back soon 19 centuries
um by some statisticians so um and and
then actually some economists got
um uh got even got the Nobel Prize by
generalizing these mobile methods to
kind of like something like what we are
discussing right now so anyway so um
so so let's see how how does this work
so I'm going to just only kind of like
I'm gonna walk you through this kind of
method by showing examples so let's do
the first example
so
um
so first example let's talk about
mixture of
of two gaussians
so you just have two gaussians and
and I think for and also I say k is two
right so and then let's also assume
P1 and P2 are just a half so these two
gaussians have the same probability so
they have the same
marginal density and also with dollars
of generality we can assume the the mean
is the average of the mean is zero so
basically they are just a symmetric
around some around origin this is in
some sense we got a lot of Charity
because you know which which point you
choose as the origin wouldn't really
matter that much
so
um
so then mu1
you can write mu-wise
so
like new to be the equals to Mu 1 and
then mu 2 is equal to minus mu so
basically we want to learn one parameter
one parameter Vector which is mu
um and the data comes from this mixture
of two gaussians whereas one gaussian is
mean mu and covariance and negative
another gaussian is mean minus mu
converts identity
right so and the moment method so
so the general approach for moment
method is the following so first
you estimate
moment
of x
using
empirical samples
I'm going to Define what exactly a
moment really mean moment really means
the I guess you know depending on
whether you have any background you know
I can all Define what moment I mean and
then what you do is you recover
um parameters
from momentum facts
and by moment we really mean something
like this so the first moment
this means the average
of x
of data
so
so the first moment okay and let's let's
try to do this you know for this
particular example right so if you do
the first moment
then the first moment is the expectation
of x
and what is the expectation of X there
are two cases one case is that you are
you have electric variable which is one
and the other case is the negative
variable is two so you can look at the
expectation of X for both of the two
gaussians right so so with half the
chance to come from the first question
and that's the case when I is 1 and half
the chance to come from the second gold
gaussian
and when it comes from the first
coefficient the mean is Mu
so that's the definition right so so you
get a half times mu and you come from
the second gaussian that means minus mu
so you get minus mu
which is zero
so this means that there's no
information
about mu
from first moment
okay
not so good right so this is not our
plan our plan is to recover meal from
the moments but from first moment we
cannot really get anything
so then what you do is you go to the
second moment
so second moment
is the expectation
[Music]
let's call it M2
maybe I should call this M1 as well so a
second moment is M2 is defined to be the
expectation of the
of the of the ultra products of X with X
itself right oh there is this
expectation of X and X transpose
so so why this is called the second
moment this is really you know this is a
matrix basically
um
basically you can see that I'm
2 i j
is the expectation of x i x j
so basically this expectation of the
kind of like the product
of two coordinates of of the data and
then you organize all of this into a
matrix and you call it M2
so and if you compute the second moment
then you can see actually mu is you know
you can you can kind of see mu from it
so how do I come to the second moment
again the same thing with half of chance
your X from the same from the same the
first option with a half of chance your
X comes from the second gaussian
and
and the way it comes from the first
caution so what's the cover what's the
what's the second moment of X under the
first caution so this requires a little
bit of calculation
so let's do that here so suppose
X come from a gaussian which mean mu and
covariance acidity
and what is the second moment
maybe let's have a different letter for
this so that we don't call it X let's
call it Z
foreign
so how do you compute this
um this so there are several ways where
one way is that you just literally look
at each of the coordinates and try to
complete expectations that's perfectly
fine so here I'm going to be a little
lazy I'm going to write that this is
equals to expectation of Z
times expect from Z transpose plus the
covariance
of C
right because covariance of Z is equals
to
the second moment minus the auto product
of the mean
and and the mean is Mu so the MU mu
transpose and the covariance is identity
so that's where we got mu mu transpose
plus energy
and and for the second so basically you
get a half times mu mu transpose
personality
and then for the second condition
actually the the movement is the same
just because mu and minus mu
is the same if you square it
to get a half times new mule transpose
So So eventually you get new mule
transpose plus identity
okay so now it looks good because at
least mu seems to come from you know
meal is uh
uh can be in something very dark from
the moment right so if you guide the
second moment you subtract I you can
recover mu
right so basically what you do is you
say you first you estimate I'm but you
don't even necessarily know I'm two
exactly right so you estimate M2
by the empirical samples
so what's the empirical samples so you
define this empirical moment
as the empirical
second moment
and and then you recover
a meal from M to hat
you know by pretending M2 is the same as
uh same as um M2 hat is the same as M2
right so for example you can recover mu
by how to do this one way to do it is
you can subtract I from M to hat and
then try to take the square square root
of it
and and here I'm going to do uh one so
so so so basically
um the key thing is that
um so how to recover right so so let's
do a warm-up so there are I guess um
in some sense to recover it from M2 hat
the first thing you want to make sure is
that you can recover it from M2
right so this is kind of like a premises
can recover
new
from M2
right and and we have argued that this
is actually true because you can just
subtract I from M2 and then take the
square root there's another way to do it
which is uh so another way
which is the spectral method
I'm going to introduce this here because
[Music]
um
um it's going to be useful for uh for
the future cases so how to recover
transpose personality what you do is you
take the top economactor
of M2
is actually equals to Mu over the norm
of mu
let's call this mu bar
so the top eigen Vector of M2 is
actually exactly in the direction of our
new bar
so and and this is something like and
also the ideal value
is the top eigenvalue is Mu two Norm
square plus identity
now this is something like you know you
can verify relatively easily right so
because eigenvector
of mu mu transpose is Mu bar
um and then eigenvector
of mu mule transpose personality is the
same
this is just because if you add
identity to animatrix you don't change
the against on the eigen system
you don't change diagram back first you
only change the eigenvalue the
eigenvalue
the eigenvalues
got
increment by one
that's that's what happens when you add
identity to a 20 Matrix
so
so so so so so
you can see that from M2 you can recover
mu either using a simple subtraction on
square root or you can do this eigen
decomposition
um and and this is the case actually
this is actually also corresponds to
the infinite data case because when you
have infinite data you can literally
compute M2 because the average will be
exactly equal to the population
so now the question becomes like what if
you don't have infinite data right you
don't have M2 you don't have M2 hat so
basically you need
uh recover from M2 head
basically using the same algorithm using
the same algorithm
on I'm too hot
so basically just use the same identity
conversation and I'm too hot and and you
need
this algorithm
to be your bus to errors
robust to errors in a sense that if you
have two matrices I'm too I'm too Health
they are similar
then applying this algorithm will give
you similar answers
right so if that's the case then you get
similar answers as if you compute it on
M2 so you got to approximate
um approximate estimate for me
right and it turns out that this
robustness thing is often okay like
um at least in in the in the in a
qualitative sense like for most of the
algorithms we're going to discuss they
are robust
to some errors so
um so so so actually the only the most
important thing would be this
so we're going to focus mostly on the
infinite data case
so we're going to focus on infinite
database
because uh most of the algorithms is
robust to errors so so the average
analysis part is important if you really
publish a paper but for the core idea
you don't have to really uh do the iron
analysis because most of the algorithms
are reasonably robust
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
any questions so far
okay so so we have basically we have
completed a discussion about
um
uh this message of two gauches and now
let's deal with mixture of three options
and you can see that the point will be
that you cannot just only use the first
moment and second moment you have to
actually go to the third moment
um and and we'll be making things a
little bit more complicated
so so maybe the general approach just to
so is that you compute
M1 which is the expectation for x
M2 which is the expectation of x x Prime
and M3 what is M3 what's the third
moment
M3 is the expectation of X tensor X
tensor X
if you're not familiar with this
notation so X tensor
X tensor X this is the third order
tensor of Dimension d by D by D
so
um and so let's say this is called T So
then T is the third order tensor
and the ijk entry of this tensor is
equals to x i times x j times x k
okay so you know in in some sense like
if you do the so X tensor X is basically
just a rewriting of x x transpose and X
tensor X tensor X is defined like this
so
and you can also have like a tensor B
tensor C so suppose
suppose T Prime is equal to a tensor B
times C
then T Prime i j k is equals to
definition would be a i times B J times
c k
so and so that's why in this sense if
you look at M3
I J K and J
then this is the
the answer of
the ijk anchi which is expectation of x
i times x j times x k
so basically every entry of this third
order tensor M3 is the expectation of
the product of three coordinates
of the of the data
so and you can do this even for M4 or M4
and I'm 5 so and so forth so and then
you design algorithm
maybe that's called a
square a
that takes in a moment
and an output
Theta so you want to recover from the
moments the parameter Theta
and then if you have if you can do this
and the last step will be that you have
to show a
is robust
on two errors
and then apply a
to the empirical moment
and how many what is the order of the
moment uh so this is this is in reality
right so this is the final algorithm
so apply a to the empirical moment at
the final algorithm all the previous
steps are kind of like the process of
Designing the algorithm so
so
um
so basically but what is the order of
the moments you have to use right so do
you need third other movement first all
the moments that depends on how from how
many moments you can recover the
parameter Theta but if from the first
moment second moment you can recover
then sure two moments are fun if you
need three moments to recover then you
need M3 otherwise you're probably even
need M4 in some cases indeed we need M4
um I guess in
yeah I think even in your case that
we're going to discuss within M for the
first time the first tense
questions
okay so I think I have only
less than about
oh I have 50 about 15 minutes
so um
I'm going to show that
um
let's talk about a mix of cake options
and I'm going to show you that you
actually need
at least
of the third moment
when the number of components is not
just two
and this is very typical in most of the
cases you need at least a third moments
actually it's not very easy to find a
case where second moment suffices like I
I have to think about you know which
case second moment suffices from Wow and
they found this like two component mix
of gaussian in almost all other cases
that you need third moment
so so let's let's uh assume again let's
make it simpler so let's assume that
this is a mixture of gaussians with a
uniform mixture
so all the components have one working
probability to show up so basically with
sample I uniformly
from K and then you generate X from
gaussian with mu mean mu I and
covariance analytic this is the genetics
model for data and alternatively you can
probably write X is sampled from
this
the average of this
10 distributions
and what you know in in all the
follow-up we are going to only do A and
B we don't know without so we only do a
and b
the step a and step B for all examples
in the SQL
even including examples in the next
lecture the robustness you know you can
do that but it requires too much kind of
like mathematical jargon which is not
really needed for this course so an A
and B is really the just is the really
the core thing that enables this so
um
so so now let's try to compute the
moment right so and see which moment is
enough for us to recover
again let's complete the first moment so
this is
um you have
K possible cases right so each case
arises with its probability K probably
the one over k
um so each cluster shows up with
probably one over okay
so condition on the cluster I your mean
is Mu I
into the sum of them this one over K
times the sum of mu y
so clearly from the first order moment
the first moment you only know the
average of the mean you probably
wouldn't be able to recover each of the
mean that sounds reasonable
so and
now let's look at a second moment
the second moment is
I guess we still do this kind of like
um total of expectation your condition
on the hidden variable I the limiting
variable I and you look at the second
moment for that that gaussian and we
have shown that for every gaussian the
the moment
is
second moment is Mu I mu I transpose
Plus anality
I take the sum from I to K
right so and then this is one over K
times sum of
basically it's the average of the author
product of mu and UI transports
plus energy
so the question becomes you know suppose
you just want to use the first moment
and a second moment
the question becomes
can we recover
from M1 and M2
right so
um or maybe more specifically from
the average of mu I
and the average of mu I mu I transpose
so and the claim is that this is not
possible
at least even K is larger than
three
so there are two kind of arguments
uh I guess you know there's one argument
the argument is the following the reason
why this is not possible is that these
are just not enough information for you
to recover in some sense so there are so
like a you're still missing some kind of
like a
um
rotations
means the rotation is likely information
okay what what does that really mean
let me specify so suppose you
just to make the discussion easier let's
define U to be this collection of
the means we will have to Mu K which is
in dimension d by K
um so this is the Matrix you want to
recover right
so
um and
I'm claiming that you're gonna exist too
set of meals that have the same
average like the same quantities here
these two quantities of the both of M1
and two are the same even though the
mules are different I'm going to
construct such a situations
how do I do that
I'm going to take
a rotation Matrix
are
in dimension K by K
I'm going to rotate so basically I'm
going to consider
U versus U times R right if you rotate
on the right hand side you got a
different type of set of means
um so I'm going to claim that U and U
times R have the same statistics you
know have have the same two quantities
um so so first thing is that if you look
at the average of the auto product Muir
mui transpose
sorry this is why we're okay then this
is one over K times uu transpose
in our simplified notation
and this is equals to 1 over K times u r
times u r transpose
this is because r r transpose is equal
to Infinity that's the definition of
rotation Matrix
so so that means that you and you are
are not distinguishable from this
quantity from the average of the product
of V1 the MU and UI transpose
so and now let's look at the
let's look at the the first other moment
so to make the first other moment also
not distinguishable I also have to take
another take
in addition
uh R such that
R times o one vector is still equal to
all one vector
so you want a rotation such that you
don't you want a rotation but you don't
want to rotate the direction of all one
vector that's easy you have on so many
rotations right you can you just want to
say I'm going to it's kind of like if
you have a globe you have One Direction
which you don't change but you can
rotate still in other immense directions
right there are still all came as two
directions but because Dimension is K
here so you still have a lot of degree
freedom to choose many different R's
that satisfies this as long as K is
someone big like louder than three
so and then suppose you satisfy this
then you are
times all one vector
or maybe let's write this so
1 over K times sum of mu I this is 1
over k
times U times open vector
right I'm claiming that this is equals
to 1 over K times U times R times R1
Vector just because I design R like this
so that's why uh from
this average column statistic
or from this quantity you still don't
distinguish
you and you are right so
you and you are
not distinguishable
because the exact can match the first
moment and second moment
so that's why we need to go to
go to
um M3 to distinguish to uniquely
identify uh The Columns of you
okay I think we are five minutes early
but I think the next thing would be
probably takes much more than five
minutes so I guess I will just stop here
uh to see whether there's any questions
uh and tomorrow the next lecture will
continue uh with solving this question
which I'm with M3
any questions
yeah so the question is how do you infer
the number of questions so first of all
you indeed you are right that in the
formulation right now
I'm assuming I know exactly the number
of options I'm even assuming that I know
all the the probabilities for each
question right P1 up to PTR exactly
equals to one over k so and the question
is how do you kind of like in front of
gaussians maybe also another question is
how do you infer the P1 to PK right so
um there are ways
um on
um of course you know there are ways
depending on you know there are various
ways depending on what assumptions you
make but definitely they are it's
possible
um for example one
somewhat
um
one way that would work in certain cases
is that you can infer the number of
gaussians by looking at
the
the rank of this Matrix
suppose you believe that all the MU eyes
are not kind of like degenerated or not
they are all in kind of like General
positions
so then the rank of this Matrix will be
k
especially for when K is less than b
right so
then you can infer number of gaussians K
by looking at the rank of this Matrix
so but but I'm not saying that that's a
actually really a great method because
in protocol you may call got into other
issues because maybe your condition is
not exactly not so and so forth so there
are many other ways
um and the Imperial empirically the most
kind of like typical way to ask the
minimum of gaussians is using
non-parametric basic methods which I
guess is not something we will cover
here so so for the theoretical setup we
are mostly interested in the cleanest I
think where you know everything when and
you you still there's still an open
question to recover the new eyes even
with the knowledge of the number of
questions
foreign
typically they are independent
so
um but they could have some kind of like
one of them you could live in
approximately the Subspace of the others
so then it becomes tricky because
whether you are robust to whatever so
and so forth yes so so I think loser
speaking is reasonable but if you really
look at the details it's not that great
so that's why you need other methods
sometimes
okay I guess so if if there's no other
questions I will see you on next Monday